Let's get back to the phones for the last
time in 2019 at (617) 830-4750.
Why don't we go to, uh Oh I don't know.
Let's go to our caller from the three three
six area code.
Who's calling today from three three six.
Hi David.
This is Dylan from North Carolina.
Hey Dylan.
What's going on?
I'm doing pretty well.
I was just thinking longterm policy, you know,
with this whole Kavanaugh situation, the Supreme
court being as it is, I'm really concerned
as to what kind of new things will come down
the pipeline.
And I'm wondering if maybe Democrats, I don't
want to say should give up on some issues,
but may be a lost cause.
I want us to talk about specifically gun control.
Um, I'm wondering if the resources we use
and specifically getting assault weapons bans,
magazine capacity bands are, are, you know,
I see a lot of people in the community, especially
the gun community, they want to counteract
these laws and the second amendment sanctuary
cities, you know, I guess my question to you
is, is should we not focus more on women's
rights, gay rights, stuff like that and whether
or not any legislation we get in, I mean,
what are the chances of it being able to be
held up, especially with the Washington DC
band being overturned?
No, I think that, so a couple things.
Number one, we should be fighting for everything
all the time because they can't stop everything.
First and foremost, that's, that's the, that's
just a reality that we have to understand.
Number two, remember the Supreme court does
not hear every case.
And so a lot of these things take a very,
very long time to really be good to get all
the way up to the Supreme court.
If the Supreme court is even going to hear
it, particularly if we're able to remove Donald
Trump in 2020, we'll have a, a, a democratic
house.
Even with a Republican Senate, there are still
things that can be done.
There are things that can be done at the state
level.
Uh, universal background checks is one that,
um, uh, is less likely that the Supreme court
would even choose to get involved in because
there, there appears to be at least far less
constitutional argument there.
And so I, I reject the idea that we shouldn't
be fighting these things.
Sure.
We have a conservative Supreme court and depending
on what happens in November of 2020, it may
become even more conservative, but the Supreme
court is not going to stop everything.
It is not going to hear every case.
And there is huge progress that can be made.
Uh, and it's, it is sort of, I mean, listen,
it's hard enough to get stuff done at the
state level and with a divided house and Senate,
the idea that we shouldn't even do it because
the Supreme court might hear it and reverse
it.
I don't think make sense whatsoever.
Okay.
All right.
Well I appreciate your answer.
Thank you so much for the call.
A great to, great to hear from you.
Hope to hear from you again.